you know it's really weird i think
somehow trump has become the center of
the cultural
universe yes dude that's why i was
saying sorry i keep interrupting you no
no no
if uh the funnier option forever
to me was trump wins again forever of
course
that's what forever i was like trump
wins again you know meltdowns and then
very recently i started to sort of
change my brain where i go
maybe the funnier option is trump loses
and just think of every like anti-trump
blog
every anti-trump you know what i mean
every reply guy on twitter
that his whole identity is hating trump
i was thinking about doing a video of
this actually but like the day after
trump wins they're just like
i guess back our bags like deletes his
twitter account
just walks off and just walks off into
the ocean
it just slowly sinks like that might be
a funnier option
but they're actually talking about it
they're talking about the future after
trump
because their whole all these media
companies
it's just trump the like i remember uh
like last week trump bought the front
page ad for the washington post online
yeah every article trump and i'm like he
just bought the front page ad dude you
need to give him every other
portion of the front page it's like he
didn't even need to buy it no but he was
he was trying to push back and
and make you know biden and kamala look
bad but
that's that's i mean what what i know
people who have made a career
a pathetic career off of just hating
trump i mean it's the oldest trick in
the book to
you know build a media company in an
election cycle or whatever you know
that's yeah
anyone who starts a blog and all that
stuff they kind of know how you do it
but they didn't even do that this time
they started a they didn't start a
media companies on a election cycle they
started a
media company on a guy yep you know and
there were some people you know i mean
there's that girl that's like getting a
netflix special her whole shtick is that
she lip syncs like trump's faces or
whatever
yeah she shouldn't even write jokes and
whatever you want to think about it
it's like what happens like to her if
trump's like just
gone yeah trump's like just a guy now
you know think about these people it's
like i have a whole youtube channel
about why trump's bad now he's just a
guy
they're gonna keep doing it yeah they
just think about it for real for real
yeah
so uh what is this what is woman's name
do you know what i mean like look what
trump ate yesterday
yeah he's racist it's gonna be like 80
year old trump in a wheelchair with a
with a with a blanket on his lap in the
sun he's gonna sit in there
and he's gonna just be like watching fox
news and they're gonna be writing
articles about it
trump reads the game they're gonna be
like did you see trump's latest
wheelchair
look at it look at it look at his nurse
his latest nurse
how old is she 40 trump going for the
young women
how despicable yeah they're like a new
guy they're going to be like i don't
know
there's it's not the same there's two
things it she has pence yeah
there's two things i think they'll still
rag on
trump they'll try for a long time so
they'll keep yeah they'll keep going
the other thing is that they'll do the
exact same thing they do
but without trump so they'll you know
like if you look at cnn he's the new
boogeyman
after trump's gone no but trumpism it'll
be about
his followers they'll maintain the same
narrative
and they will make they'll just keep
going after it's like
the the the the painting exists they'll
take trump out of it but the whole
landscape it's still there
yeah so i think what's likely to happen
is you got these companies
cnn their whole sunday morning program
is literally like fox news all day every
day
and i make fun of them all time for it
because i'm like dude you realize you
guys are just the fox news review
channel right
yeah yeah like when when i complain
about the mainstream media it's always
like
it's a bunch of different outlets and
i'm complaining and and often say not
every single journalist at these outlets
of course
it's these like political you know you
know uh politicos in the beltway in dc
but they literally have a show where
it's like the dude wrote a book about
fox news
yeah that's all he has that's crazy
no and and and trump but when trump's
gone they
that schtick they've developed it's not
gonna go away i mean look russia
you're familiar with russia i'm not
saying necessarily it'll go away i'm
gonna say i'm
more saying that no one's gonna want to
watch it so they can keep doing it
and they'll be like we'll keep doing the
plug in the model it's like instead of
being like can you believe what trump
said they'll just have to you know can
you believe
i don't know like they'll pick another
guy right but i don't think anyone's
gonna care like
what the gets the clicks is trump goes
out says some crazy stuff you know
and then they go look at this crazy
stuff he's saying and then the
right-wing
obligations go look at this crazy stuff
they're saying it's not even about what
trump says
it's like trump stirs up some energy and
they get to write an article they they
stir it up i mean sometimes trump for
sure trump loves stirring
just almost swearing trump loves to stir
it up
yeah but there will be times where like
trump will walk in the room and i'll go
thank you all for coming and they'll go
and they'll be writing like did you hear
what he said thank you all
who's all who's yeah the soccer they're
like soccer players
that god
[Laughter]
that's the perfect way to explain it
yeah trump trump walks in and pats him
on the shoulder and cnn goes
and they fall down and they're like
they're writing 50 articles
they're uh what was that one article we
were talking about from um
the nation it was like they took every
single possible negative stereotype
about you it was like
ivanka or something yeah so they wrote
an entire article about ivanka's
dress or something and it just like
crammed keywords into this article where
it was like
white nationalists think that
transgender feminists in the patriarchy
with red dresses and it's like it was
very clearly a nonsensical article
had no premise and they stuffed all the
keywords into it so they could put it on
google and google would prop it up yeah
that's like
that's the name of the game but no i
think that's wild it it is it is funny
i'll tell you this
when trump won in 2016 i laughed harder
than i've left it was like
one of the funniest things ever i've
ever seen it was because
for one for me it was like cathartic the
democrats getting comeuppance
you know they they cheated bernie they
thought they're going to win they made
fun of trump they mocked his supporters
anyone puritanical like uh losing the
battle that they
you know their entire identity of is
always like and so so right now
you bring up an interesting point
because i've said this too i've said if
biden wins i'm just going to laugh
i'm going to laugh really really hard
yeah funny either way i think at this
point
i'm worried i'm worried like so i'm
going to be voting for trump and and the
riots are the main are you going full
mega you get a mega beanie no mag
they want people want me to win i don't
like vote i don't like i don't like
supporting any tribe or any party or
anything like that but i'll tell you
this with all the riots
especially how bad how bad it was last
night the only reason the democrats came
out now this is this is so messed
up they've been saying peaceful protests
over and over again nonstop
and then don lemon comes out on cnn and
he's like this is starting to show up in
the polls
democrats better address it it's like oh
is that the only thing you cared about
should they
that made me angry and so you know
seeing all this this death 32 people
have died
i'm just like they keep lying about this
and trump keeps saying we got to stop
the violence
and and when they don't do it they blame
him for it and i'm like
the president doesn't have the right to
intervene in the states and localities
that's local law enforcement
and trump keeps saying please i've got
law enforcement you can use them and
they say no
more people die please national guard no
more people die
finally now they're starting to say yes
and so that that pissed me off so now
i'm like you know what man
i'm gonna vote for trump i think he's he
he wants to withdraw our troops from
afghanistan he wants to do uh term
limits
he's gonna he wants to end the riots he
wants to prosecute these extremists
fine whatever i'm done with these i
heard he was gonna remove the women's
uh vote which is a nice yeah yeah yeah
straight up yeah
number one agenda repeal the 19th yeah
there is a third party and i don't know
if you know this tim but i've also
decided i was going to run for president
as the first president exclusively for
the boys
oh yeah yeah i don't know if you guys
heard this men will pay no taxes
and that will girls will pay double the
taxes oh yeah cause a girl has cooties
no girlfriends are allowed to take their
boys friends on saturdays
so that's my platform i love it i i'm
gonna need you to speak to some of your
friends at google in high up places
because uh as a canadian they have well
have banned me from running but
there's good news we're working on that
dj there was an op-ed in the washington
post saying that we should remove the
natural-born citizen requirement
yes no i'm like that's the get out of
here
i do think i do think it's fun it i i
will if biden wins i'm going to laugh
because you know why because i'm i'm not
i'm i'm not the kind of person who's
going to like sulk and cry
i'm going to laugh and be like this is a
crazy yeah
like a cultural commentator i think that
uh
your personal viewpoint is like a
percentage of what you do but i don't
think that
influences you entirely well i you know
i i think everything i say about
everything is
exactly what i believe it's just raw
consciousness i don't know well there's
yeah but if you were talking about the
facts of something i don't know if
you're
will you tell me like when you're
talking about something like do you
consider that you're like this is what i
think or do you sometimes
be like i'm no i'm telling you what
happened well yeah
so a lot of the articles i do i'm like
here's the story here's what i think and
then here's what i think
but everything i think is literally what
i think and i don't want biden to win
i think he's i don't think he's all with
it
that's worrying to me no i mean
understatement of the year
for sure for sure come on completely
he's
he's he's like cosmic joe he's in outer
space at the time yeah dude both these
guys are like a thousand years old but
yeah trump's way more with it for sure
for sure and and as far as i'm concerned
he's the one who's been consistent on
like look we had a great
first three years with the economy and
so i give him credit for that he's he's
improved a bit
but anyway the point i was trying to
bring up is not like to be like hey
trump just to be like
i'm not gonna if if trump wins i'm gonna
be like wow
because the thing that scares me the
most is that all this wokeness stuff
that we've been making fun of and
laughing about
it's it's infecting these these uh
government agencies it already happened
yeah you know the cdc
10 of their staff demanded a nationwide
health crisis
uh uh they want racism to be cleared in
nationwide health crisis yeah i know
10 people don't realize man you get 10
of a staff and i was i was reading a
study that said 10 is all you need for
an ideology to dominate a culture
so if the cdc actually starts divorce
enforcing this insanity it's like
you've got you've got some democratic
politicians calling on joe biden to
condemn the people defending property
not the extremists who are burning it
down right that scares me
and i think we're headed towards like
you know dark times but i'll tell you
what
i'm leaving where i'm at and all you can
do
is like i think a lot of times all you
can do is laugh
yeah like so so buying one i i've left
and and it's not because
the purpose of laughter like in the
first place from a
legitimate you know evolutionary level
it's like when things get too bad it's
like you can release pressure
right right right it is right so either
way no matter who wins i'm gonna go out
to the middle of nowhere i'm gonna get
some goats and some chickens and just
like kick back and grow some
tomatoes or whatever that called to go
to the vice one last job one last job
tim
open the big briefcase with one little
tiny ring no but you are right like the
amount of times people kind of
say you know i'm making all these videos
about this stuff and this the people
that are kind of wrapped up in this go
oh as if it's like that and then the
rest of the world messaged me like it's
exactly like that
yeah you know i've been working at these
companies it's insane the
output it's getting worse yeah i mean so
unless unless we straight up say
no hard no yeah and everyone kind of has
but it's you know it's again it's it's
hard to fight
if you're a normal person because it's
one thing where
you say oh you know this guy disagrees
with me it's another thing where they go
this guy is racist and a normal person
goes what
i don't know i'm not and they go yeah
he's transphobic at home and you're like
dude
like they don't you know if you're some
guy working at some job it's hard to
deal with this stuff
if trump wins every state i think it'll
be the end of
the woke insurrection whatever because
because i think
the farmer could go the other way though
right like a lot of this is a temper
tantrum right
it's like that's why i was saying one of
the things i was gonna do a video about
being the first president that runs
exclusively on 20 year old girl opinions
the lifeblood of the media
seriously a lot of these candidates have
one or you know 10 20 year old girl
opinions i have
all 21 neural call opinions but it is
kind of that right so
i don't know it's a temper tantrum
you've got a small group
but it's growing and they are
dominating our cultural institutions our
big media brands our advertisers our
news outlets
but they don't make up anywhere near the
majority they're probably not even they
probably just barely cracked the double
digits
they make up probably the majority of
the institutions you know whether that
be hollywood no no
i don't think so you don't think in the
universities i think
it's a strong enough percentage and
they're terroristic
and so they get what they want whatever
they want yeah yeah so uh
that's why there are professors who get
fired who because
some people will stand up and say no and
they'll get kicked out based professors
well brett weinstein you know his story
with evergreen yeah so it's like an
interview with uh james lindsay about it
yeah yeah so uh you know brett's he's
he's a progressive guy but he's not
insane like these people are
so i think it is funny how guys like
that kind of got thrown into like the
bad boy thing
yeah and but he's still wearing like
khaki shorts right you know he's kind of
showing up like
the bad boy university professor and
he's got like the polo shirt in the game
yeah
not not sandals and socks not considered
to be like a celebrity hip guy yeah yeah
but you know he's all right right
so but imagine this netflix right they
put up their their black lives matter
message
what do you think happens when everyone
looks at the election results and it's
just like trump 50 state suite
then these companies are going to be
like we're marketing them do you think
that's possible
yeah right now they're saying he's going
to lose like but the polls are always no
no right now trump's winning did it just
switch so
uh several polls have come out recently
trump's ahead in wisconsin and he's
trailing biden in 15 battleground states
according to cnn by one point with a
four-point margin of error
so actually i think i might it's so hard
to get information right now you turn on
here
and it's like yeah people are scared
dude we got this sweet this is from
uh walker bragman who's this guy he's a
journalist
for i don't know i don't know a podcast
but check this out
he says august 24th 2016 in wisconsin
clinton's up 11.5
pennsylvania 9.2 north carolina 1.7
florida 3.6
michigan 8 ohio 4.8 joe biden's margins
today
are lower than clinton's why did you
think this changed like why did uh
why did trump go back up uh joe biden's
been hiding in the basement
and i'm not kidding he's literally in
his home basement he's hiding
and the riots have been getting worse we
just had two guys killed yesterday
and joe biden was hiding in his basement
donald trump was tweeting up a storm
so you can complain about trump you know
in his obnoxious tweets
but he's there joe biden came out with a
statement today that was that was bland
and nonsensical
we must get justice for this man and you
know violence doesn't solve anything
john biden comes out joe biden comes out
with a statement he's like i like to
make a statement
we here at the house are out of peanut
butter
please help us look fat we got only
about
two tablespoons left feet pudding and my
my my my pants are wet i don't know why
where's jill poor joe yeah for joe
so uh so this is a run out of denture
cream if anyone would be
so kind as to bring me some more i have
a zoo dude
interview with charlemagne trumpet yeah
trump is trump's old but like
he doesn't come off like biden does he i
wish
i hope when i'm like trump's age i'm
that chipper yeah
dude i guess what's trump 74
he's spry yeah you know what i mean joe
biden is like
so so anyway there's a lot of reasons
why uh trump's been improving in the
polls
there's two things not only is the race
tightening this is probably because
uh biden is in my opinion not actually
running
i mean like he's literally he's
literally running but he's not
campaigning he's not doing anything
i mean they're buying ads but come on
he's not making appearance he's not
rallying he's not going out
and and politics is a is a ground game
you got to go out there you got to meet
people you got to kill you
you got to shake babies and kiss hands
you know what i mean he's doing i'm
kidding the other way around no yeah
he's doing the like i hope trump just
screws up so bad that they're like all
right enough of this i don't i
i i think they're completely inept i
think the challenge right now for the
democrats is that you got riots
where people are dying 32 people and
the [ __ ] i just got shot we were just
talking about yeah well two guys and and
so you've got
the far left that endorses this stuff
they love it yeah they're stupid when
when the when the looting happened in
chicago
black lives matter came out and said
good what they did was reparations
i'm glad good for them so what's joe
biden supposed to say
the riots are bad then then he's going
to lose half of the left he's going to
lose all these young woke far leftists
if he comes if he comes out and says or
if he comes out and says the rights are
good then he's going to lose everybody
to trump
so he's just like i don't know what to
do so he just hides in the basement i
guess the idea is i mean
i kind of argued this a little bit
different than what you're saying is
that because i
i felt a lot of people on the internet
are kind of saying you know
uh and i and i do see it that kamal was
a bad choice but i have had some people
in normal life that are kind of your
middle of the road swing voters
and they see kamala as like oh someone's
sensible so i think there are some
people that yeah
i was i was talking to some family
members who said that you know what i
mean yeah in the chicago suburbs they're
looking at kamalas like oh
thank heavens the democrats have brought
in someone who can stop the riots i
100 some people see it as like okay
she's not a crazy radical
i'm not i'm not going to vote for her
you know like like i'm here to vote for
a president not for an old feeble man
who's going to hire someone to the job
for him
my vote is not for and i don't look i
don't like himalayas i think she's awful
i think she's an authoritarian
and a lot of people uh like that she's
gonna do something
and they don't like trump so i i think
you know i i don't think i think right
now
it's close it's a close race with trump
according to these polls
i think trump's in the lead based off of
the beltway bubble which is these
journalists who only follow each other
and i think the polls are skewed because
they don't know how to pull trump's base
and that's
that was true in 2016 and they admit
it's true today they don't know what to
do no you can't trust these polls as far
as you can throw them
but when when when the polls are coming
out now saying trump's within the margin
of error
then it's probably he's several points
up and i i i just can't believe
that with the riots going on for three
months like have you have you heard any
c-span phone calls
these people these people call in and
this this like lady's like
we've had riots in my town i'm in
minnesota i mean in minneapolis and the
democrats didn't say anything about it
what about us
she's like within two days of the
republican convention i feel like
there's hope again to like deal with
this
and the guy on c-span answers like are
you scared of the riots and she's like
yes
yeah no some people are they're like you
know i think i mean lots of people said
this that trump's just gonna be like
yeah i'm just gonna get things back to
normal so no one's smashing your windows
and everyone's like yeah all in dude
like that's enough
but it's true what you said like if you
know we're saying that
if uh if trump gets in or trump loses
like all these people you're like what
did he even talk about
it's the same kind of thing it's like if
the left just said like
yeah remember we got a little out of
hand we're not gonna do this identity
politics stuff anymore we're not gonna
tell everyone that they're racist
everyone would be like all right you're
back in and then the right would be like
because
there's a lot that's just like yo this
stuff's whack
so but all it takes is it wouldn't be
that hard for them to do that but they
won't right so
it's just too ingrained they're too
crazy people are too sick of that stuff
gallup poll shows that the dominant wing
of the democratic party is
the the you know strong liberal or
whatever
so the moderate and conservative
democrats of you know the past 10 20 30
years they're gone
they probably join the republican party
because we see that data too and they're
not going to give it up because these
young people who are trying to take over
are uh they're they're in the cult dude
i see so many young people there like 20
that they don't even care about politics
there's like yo i'm a trump guy that's
hilarious yeah
the same way that you know if if your
parents or like your millennial parents
are like
jump the devil if you like trump you're
the worst and you're like yo give me a
mega hat
well there's the inverse to that the
maga parents and the kids being like
f you trump sucks and then they go on
poster tick tocks and stuff for sure
but i think it's more the other way
around because
the the pervasive like it
it's it's different because it's
everyone's it's your parents are also
saying the same thing that everyone's
saying
yeah you know it's more like before if
you had liberal parents it's like i
don't think you would have done this
right
exactly you know it's only only it used
to work the other way like you had the
religious parents and you're like i'm
actually going to be a prostitute
right now you've got like this 16 year
old kid whose mom is like super
anti-trump temperature yeah she's
religious about trump
and he walks in he walks in with the hat
and she's like what are you doing billy
he goes shut up mom
2020 yeah and she's like oh i'm
listening to the boss
can you imagine though if you had a mom
like and you came in and you go just so
you know there's no such thing as gender
and you're like mom i'm a boy and you're
like no you're not
you know it's how messy mom i'm a boy no
you're not
i do not have a son no no apparently not
you're like you i'm not i'm not gay you
might be gay
stop being a bigot yeah dude open your
heart
mom stop it's my girlfriend you got to
bring home your
you know to that your mom comes home and
she's like uh this is my mom and she's
like
like this this is my parents she doesn't
identify as a mom or dad
parental figure number one yeah you'd be
so afraid to ever bring your
like you would rebel against that so
hard you know i'd be embarrassing you
yeah i would be going to school with an
american flag on my back if i was that
guy yep you're canadian yeah
i was even in canada i'd be full in i'd
macho
i'd be macho man randy savage with a
flag on my back oh yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you